le jour de mes 12 ans j'ai reçu une
lettre d'une amie dans laquelle ils me
demandaient
qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus tard
quand tu seras grande
et je lui ai répondu je ne sais pas
pourquoi
compositrice
tout en lui écrivant ce mot
je me suis dit
compositrice n'importe quoi
personne ne fait de la musique à la
maison
ils viennent doucement il ne pouvait pas
venir de moi c'était tellement loin de
ma réalité
alors je les laisser partir avec cette
lettre
cette année là ma mère m'a inscrite au
conservatoire de ma région
il fallait que je fasse du piano comme
toutes les filles de ses amis
c'était dur la maison
d'enchaîner trois heures de piano par
jour
mon frère et ma soeur
regardez la petite maison dans la
prairie et starsky hutch sans le son
le week end
j'allais même chez des gens qui avaient
un grand piano
dans une grande maison
parce que les voisins de mon immeuble
avait appelé la police
je faisais trop de bruit
il
ya de quoi devenir fou à écouter mes
gamins
au conservatoire
j'ai passé mon temps à décortiquer des
partitions
mesure par mesure
rythme paris demain
mon prof me répéter
tu as de la technique ouais mais tout ça
ça manque d'émotion
de quelles émotions me parlait-il
j'ai jamais appris à jouer une émotion
alors
j'ai écouté en boucle
de grands interprètes
comme arthur rubinstein
samson françois
alfred brendel
et d'autres grands illustre pianiste
j'apprenais parker
ou respirer
ou accélérer
ou ralentir
et même où m un peu d'émotion
le jour où j'ai eu le premier prix à
l'examen de sortie
je pensais réellement que ce serait
accepter dans un grand conservatoire
celui de paris la fois royal
je croyais que avec beaucoup d'efforts
je pouvais y arriver oui
c'était ma volonté de bien faire compter
plus que tout
mais ce jour là mon prof est arrivé et
m'a dit
fais pas pianiste
je te vois bien
ingénieurs 1
ce qu'il m'a dit ce jour là
m'a transpercé
ses douleurs je les gardais ici en moi
et en fait j'ai compris qu'il n'avait
jamais cru en moi mais pourquoi avoir
attendu six ans pour me le dire
ces six longues années il fallait que je
les récupère quelque part
il fallait rattraper ce temps perdu
je devais quitter mes parents quitté ma
région
il fallait absolument que j'enterre ce
piano
je me suis juré ce jour là de ne plus
jamais toucher aucune notes de piano
j'ai parcouru le monde entier
en faisant des métiers les uns plus
beaux que les autres
enseignante formatrice
responsable des relations
internationales
auditrice financière psychothérapeute
coach je crois que j'aurais pu faire
encore d'autres métiers
il fallait rattraper ce temps perdu je
ne m'autorisais jamais à m'arrêter
je ne prenais même pas de vacances
et parfois
j'ai oublié même d'aller aux toilettes
il fallait rattraper le temps perdu
mais en mars 2018
je me suis autorisé
trois jours de congé
j'étais si fatiguée par le travail
je voulais faire le vide dans ma tête
chez moi
j'étais avachi dans le fauteuil vert
pomme de mon salon
et là
j'ai entendu
des coups tout a coûté contre la vitre
de mon salon
elle tombe et
infatigable sur le bitume
il y avait de la buée sur le bord des
fenêtres
segundo cliqueter sur les gouttières
et ce concert de cliquetis
commencé à me motiver
alors je me suis levé tout doucement
pour mieux les entendre
et ils ont commencé
à sonner à mes oreilles comme le
d'une horloge
suivi par un tabac
cela faisait
et je me suis dirigé machinalement
vers mon petit numéro
petit piano numérique que jamais ouverte
et un vieux cadeau de ma mère
j'ai poussé
bougies bibelots
photos
qui avaient servi à enterrer mon piano
et mes doigts se sont mis à jouer tout
seul
[Musique]
bach
e
en
[Musique]
on
e
ah ah
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
pratique
et j'ai joué j'ai joué sans pouvoir
m'arrêter
tout en versant des
larmes de tout mon corps
j'ai pleuré tout ce que j'ai retenu en
moi depuis 30 ans
ce sont ces notes là que j'aurais aimé
jouer au conservatoire
ce jour là j'ai eu accès à ces notes
unique
parce que j'ai commencé
à prendre le temps de faire de la place
à l'intérieur de moi
oui cette mélodie est venu faire de la
place pour moi alors aujourd'hui
tous les matins je me lève
et je compose au piano des mélodies
inspirées et inspirantes
et vous savez quoi
cet ami qui m'a contacté
quand gervais 12 ans
elle m'a écrit un peu avant noël alors
que je préparais ceux des leaks
elle m'a demandé
qu'est ce que tu deviens
alors je me suis empressé de lui dire tu
te souviens de la lettre que tu m'as
envoyé quand j'avais 12 ans tu me
demandais ce que je voulais faire plus
tard quand je serai grande
et bien aujourd'hui je suis compositrice
la mélodie que je vais jouer est pour
toi
elle est aussi pour vous
aujourd'hui
je vous invite à une immersion
mélodique
ressentez là comme une symphonie
où chacun et chacune d'entre nous
jouons notre note unique
on y va
[Musique]
m
aum
on
[Musique]
e
merci
[Applaudissements]